Mesdames et Messieurs les directrices
directeurs généraux d'organisation
internationale Monsieur le Secrétaire
général
mesdames et messieurs vos grades et
qualités parce que je ne reconnaîtrais
pas tout le monde ni dans la salle ni
dans les escaliers je sais qu'il y a
aussi beaucoup de parlementaires de
chefs d'entreprise merci d'être là cher
Christopher amis
je suis heureux de pouvoir vous
retrouver aujourd'hui
dans ce lieu où depuis presque 60 ans
s'anime de nombreux débats qui
structure notre monde et nourrissent le
champ de réflexion de la communauté
transatlantique mais aujourd'hui comme
nous venons de le voir avec le président
zellinski et le chancelier schols qui
m'ont précédé dont je salue les
interventions à l'instant l'heure est
évidemment à la gravité
dans quelques jours il se sera écoulé un
an depuis le lancement de la
catastrophique guerre d'agression menée
par la Russie contre l'Ukraine et même
si ça n'est pas l'heure des conclusions
c'est déjà celle d'un bilan et je le
crois de quelques perspectives communes
que nous pouvons nous donner alors je
vais donc concentrer mon propos sur
évidemment la guerre lancée par la
Russie en Ukraine mais je veux dire ici
que nous n'en oublions pas pour autant
les guerres dans le Caucase au proche
Moyen-Orient en Afrique la lutte contre
le terrorisme les questions de sécurité
nucléaires qui sont aussi posées dans
d'autres régions etc etc
mais c'est bien de l'Ukraine dont nous
allons parler aujourd'hui
alors un an après le bilan est
considérable d'un conflit catastrophique
et injustifié et je voudrais ici au fond
insister sur un point
c'est que cette guerre contrairement à
ce que je lis trop souvent n'est pas
simplement la guerre des européennes et
des Européens elle touche la planète
entière
d'abord parce que c'est une agression
privée de toute justification et que je
qualifierai comme je l'ai fait la
tribune de l'Assemblée générale des
Nations unies il y a quelques mois
donner aux colonial et d'impérialiste
c'est bien cette vision du monde qui
domine dans cette agression qui dénit
l'identité à un voisin qui considère
qu'on peut prendre une part de son
territoire voire la totalité de celui-ci
sans respect et qui s'arroche une forme
de droit de tutelle sur un autre peuple
et l'accepter détourner le regard fermez
les yeux c'est considérer que
le néocolonialisme ou la puissance
impériale et légitime ou que ce soit
dans le reste du monde
la deuxième chose c'est que au nom de
cette vision du monde ce sont tous les
tabous qui ont été brisés
pas seulement celui de la violation de
la Charte des Nations Unies qui a été
assumée par une puissance membre
permanent du Conseil de sécurité
mais des meurtres des viols des crimes
de guerre des destructions systématiques
d'infrastructures civiles et donc une
systématisation des crimes de guerre
contre le peuple ukrainien mais
également des menaces nucléaires et je
veux ici saluer le travail sans relâche
conduit par la UEA depuis le début et
son directeur général monsieur grossi
en Ukraine d'ailleurs comme en Iran car
ce sujet ne quitte pas nos esprits
enfin cette agression assure le monde
des effets calamiteux dont la Russie
porte l'entière responsabilité
la crise alimentaire le renchérissement
inouïe le prix des matières premières en
dépit des mesures de solidarité que nous
prenons vis-à-vis des pays les plus
vulnérables et je sais que pour certains
de nos partenaires dans le monde disent
c'est une affaire européenne il y a des
torts partagés je veux les inviter à
quitter ce relativisme il y a bien un
agresseur et un agressé et il y a
surtout des principes qui sous-tendent
cette agression qui sont clairs et que
nous ne pouvons pas laisser gagner si
nous souhaitons un ordre international
stable et une paix durable
le deuxième grande remarque que je
souhaitais faire c'est que d'ores et
déjà
l'agression russe a été
consacré couronné si je puis dire par
quatre échecs clairs le premier échec
c'est celui du terrain
l'hypothèse de base c'est que cette
agression serait rapide que l'Ukraine ne
résisterait pas et que c'était une
affaire de quelques jours voire de
quelques semaines
le courage extraordinaire des armées et
du peuple ukrainien
de ces dirigeants toutes ces forces
politiques et je salue ici l'ensemble
des amis que je retrouve dans cette
salle et le président qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure derrière l'écran
ont déjoué se plant terrible et la
résistance acquiète la reprise du Nord
puis ce qui a été fait à Kerson à car
qui fait d'entendre en droit on marqué
un échec du plan militaire russe initial
le deuxième échec c'est celui de la
mentalité coloniale
très clairement
il y a eu un discours qui a cherché à au
fond crée la confusion entre zone
d'influence et zones de coercition et à
expliquer qu'il y avait une légitimité à
ce conflit
ça n'a pas réussi un an après je vais
ici dire clairement que notre devoir à
tous et de continuer ce travail
consistant à expliquer expliciter le
fait que la Russie aujourd'hui est une
puissance de déséquilibre et de désordre
qui passe simplement en Ukraine mais
dans le Caucase au proche Moyen-Orient
en Afrique par l'autrichement de Wagner
parce que cette guerre a permis aussi
d'expliciter ce qui était une ambiguïté
voire une hypocrisie qu'on connaissait
ces dernières années moi-même il y a un
an j'étais en Russie pour essayer de
péder la paix président Poutine me
disait avec une confiance que je croyais
relative mais à laquelle je croyais
quand même ces gens de Wagner sont pas à
nous une pause aussi des problèmes en
Russie ils ont maintenant officialisé le
fait que Wagner était un truchement
explicite direct
diplomatique au militaire
neomafieux de la Russie partout dans le
monde et va continuer au fond
l'international du crime et du désordre
nous l'avons mis en échec de manière
relative mais nous devons aller au bout
de ce travail
le troisième échec de la Russie c'est un
échec à lire l'avenir
le résultat concret c'est la
consolidation
de l'Ukraine et de sa force c'est le
choix fait par la Finlande et la Suède
de rejoindre l'OTAN et je veux dire ici
aux dirigeants combien nous sommes à
leur côté sur ce chemin c'est également
des dépendances internationales accrues
un prestige entamé sur tous les plans
une méfiance profondément enracinée et
une défiance légitime que beaucoup dans
la région peuvent avoir comment peut-on
croire que les défis du Caucase
seront réglés par
la Russie et au coloniale que je décris
je le dis devant mon ami Premier
ministre pachinian aux côtés duquel nous
continuons de nous tenir et nous
continuerons d'agir
et puis quatrième échec qui est sans
doute le plus troublant c'est
aujourd'hui celui du président Poutine à
rendre à la Russie ce qui lui a promis
c'est son autorité dans le monde car au
fond comment la Russie peut-elle se
satisfaire d'être un producteur de
matière première plutôt qu'une économie
de création peut se satisfaire d'un
produit intérieur brut médiocre malgré
les atouts d'une puissance mondiale et
maintenant d'une suspicion généralisée
de tous les voisins
alors ils ont dit tout cela je peux vous
redire aisément ce que je défendais sur
cette même estrade il y a deux ans
aucun d'entre nous ne changera la
géographie de la Russie elle sera
toujours sur le sol européen
et aucun d'entre nous ne pourra conjurer
ce qui est aujourd'hui une fatalité mais
notre dilemme c'est qu'il n'y aura pas
de paix durable et complète sur notre
continent sans que nous ne sachions
embrasser la question russe mais de
manière lucide sans aucune complaisance
mais c'est une réalité et c'est bien
sans cet esprit là qui nous faut
continuer d'avancer sans faciliter c'est
ce qui a d'ailleurs conduit
mon action mes expressions depuis le
début de ce conflit et avant pas de
faciliter pas de naïveté une vraie
détermination la force qu'on nous devons
la voir mais aussi le courage du
réengagement du dialogue pour trouver
des solutions durables mais très
clairement aujourd'hui
l'heure n'est pas au dialogue parce que
nous avons une Russie qui a choisi la
guerre qui a choisi d'intensifier la
guerre et qui a choisi d'aller jusqu'au
crime de guerre et à l'attaque des
infrastructures civiles
alors la conclusion de court terme que
nous devons tirer de ce schéma est
simple
la Russie ne peut ni ne doit gagner
cette guerre
et l'agression russe doit échouer
parce qu'on ne peut pas accepter la
banalisation du recours illégal à la
force
parce que sinon c'est toute la sécurité
européenne mais plus généralement la
stabilité mondiale qui serait remise en
cause c'est pour cela que nous avons
avec nos partenaires européens
américains et plusieurs autres depuis le
début était aux avant-postes de cette
sécurité de ce soutien sanction 10
paquets de sanctions prises par les
Européens
sur la Russie depuis le début et
soutient militaire économique
humanitaire à l'égard de l'Ukraine et de
son peuple avec des conférences de
soutien sur les infrastructures des
infrastructures civiles
des équipements qui ont été transférés
des financements une mobilisation de
tout le temps et merci Monsieur le
Secrétaire général pour tout le travail
fait et la France a privilégié à chaque
fois les secteurs de plus fortes valeurs
ajoutées compte tenu des attentes
ukrainiennes l'artillerie la défense
antiérienne en particulier avec aussi un
programme de formation pour des milliers
de soldats et c'est pourquoi dans le
même temps nous avons assumé également
de renforcer pour ce qui nous concerne
en particulier en Roumanie en Estonie et
dans le ciel européen notre défense du
flanc Est de l'OTAN
mais également en renforçant notre
présence en Méditerranée ou notre groupe
aéronaval participe à la réassurance ça
c'est la stratégie assumée dès les
premiers jours du conflit parce que se
renforcement par exemple sur le sol
roumain nous l'avons traduit en acte sur
le sol dès la fin du mois de février
2022 et c'est ce que nous allons
continuer et renforcer
parce qu'au moment où je vous parle ma
conviction est que nous devons
absolument intensifier notre soutien et
notre effort pour aider à la résistance
du peuple et de l'armée ukrainienne et
leur permettre de mener la
contre-offensive qui seule
permettra de négociations crédibles aux
conditions choisies par l'Ukraine ses
autorités et son peuple
et donc bien qu'espérance si je puis
dire être surpris par la paix nous
sommes prêts à intensifier aujourd'hui
car les semaines et les mois qui
viennent sont décisifs et nous sommes
prêts à un conflit prolongé en disant
cela je ne le souhaite pas
mais surtout s'il ne le souhaitons pas
nous devons collectivement être crédible
dans notre capacité à durer dans cet
effort et c'est ainsi que la France
s'inscrit dans celui-ci voilà à la fois
l'état d'esprit la détermination la
volonté qui est la nôtre aujourd'hui aux
côtés de l'Ukraine car c'est le seul
moyen de faire revenir à la table des
discussions de manière acceptable la
Russie est de construire une paix
durable c'est-à-dire au moment et dans
des conditions qui seront choisies par
les Ukrainiens
ayant dit cela je souhaitais lancer
quelques appels en ce moment à mes amis
européens
et qui viennent compléter poursuivre
cette ces quelques convictions que je
viens de partager le premier appel c'est
un appel à réinvestir massivement dans
notre défense
si nous Européens voulons la paix nous
devons nous en donner les moyens
la France prend sa part après une revue
nationale stratégique que j'ai présenté
en novembre dernier gouvernement vient
de soumettre à la représentation
nationale un projet de loi de
programmation militaire qui portera
notre budget sur la période 2024-2030 à
400 milliards d'euros soit 100 milliards
d'euros de plus que sur la période
précédente c'est une augmentation
considérable et les Européens ont besoin
de faire cet effort
mais réarmer
c'est aussi renforcer la base
industrielle et technologique de défense
faire vivre et amplifier tous les
mécanismes que nous avons développés
récemment notamment à travers l'agenda
dit de Versailles il y a presque un an
de nombreux États qui voudraient aider à
armer l'Ukraine dépendent aujourd'hui en
effet parfois de décisions de pays non
européens et de beaucoup d'industriels
non européens
et si l'Europe veut pouvoir défendre
l'Europe elle doit aussi s'armer
profiter de l'interopérabilité de l'OTAN
mais accélérer sa capacité à produire
sur le sol européen je souhaite donc que
nous adoptions avant l'été un ambitieux
programme européen d'investissement de
défense
et dans l'immédiat que nous tirions le
meilleur parti du Fonds européen de
défense
ce sont aussi nos cadences qu'il faut
revoir entre-européens nous devons
regarder comment produire plus et plus
vite et cette économie de guerre que dès
le printemps nous avons voulu renforcer
en France nous devons aller encore plus
loin aller vers plus de standardisation
plus de simplification et le faire en
Europe
le second appel est un appel à prendre
en compte le facteur nucléaire dans
cette crise
chacun au cours de l'année écoulé a pu
mesurer l'importance
d'un des non-dits de ce conflit
oserais-je dire parfois par certains
d'un des trodis de ce conflit l'arme
nucléaire
l'agression russe a été menée à Londres
de la dissuasion
et la dissuasion a constitué un élément
important de l'autre côté de la
protection des alliés
cette situation est un rappel à l'ordre
sur l'importance du rôle que joue et
doit continuer de jouer l'arme nucléaire
dans l'Union européenne et dans le temps
la dissuasion française
occupe une place spécifique qui
contribue en Europe de même que celle du
Royaume-Uni au renforcement global de la
sécurité de l'Alliance
évidemment nos alliés américains jouent
un rôle essentiel aussi à cet égard
et je souhaite que nous réinfirmions le
caractère nucléaire de l'Alliance
atlantique et que nous en tirions toutes
les conséquences dans l'ensemble des
enceintes internationales
je souhaite également réitérer mon offre
formulée à l'école de guerre en février
2020 d'un dialogue avec les partenaires
européens qui le souhaitent sur la
dissuasion nucléaire française et la
conception qu'à la France de la
dimension européenne de ces intérêts
vitaux
en troisième appel est un appel à
repenser notre doctrine de sécurité
pour assurer la place de l'Europe dans
toute future discussion de maîtrise des
armements
un exemple me frappe en particulier qui
concerne les missiles de portée
intermédiaire et j'avais l'occasion
d'ailleurs lors d'un des sommets fin
2019 de l'otanian s'en souvient sans
doute de souligner la situation
ubuesque dans laquelle nous nous
trouvions les États-Unis avec une autre
administration décidante sortir de
certains traités que les Russes depuis
des années ne respectaient plus qui
concernait notre seul sans que nous
soyons parti prenante
cette situation en quelque sorte de
minorité géopolitique des Européens nous
devons en sortir il s'agit de la
sécurité de l'Europe nous devons la
penser nous devons la produire nous
devons la négocier nous devons l'assurer
avec nos alliés de l'OTAN mais aussi en
tant que européen
les armes je le disais de porter
intermédiaire était régie par le Traité
sur les forces nucléaires intermédiaires
la France n'était pas partie à ce traité
nous en avons respecté les dispositions
que nous avons constaté qu'il n'y avait
plus aucun traité qui couvrait ce risque
et bien je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous
devons en tirer toutes les conséquences
ce serait un ajout légitime au
dispositif de protection de l'Europe de
raviver des négociations en ce sens
ensuite l'Europe doit prendre sa place à
la table des futurs négociations sur ce
type d'instrument et ce sujet rejoint
aussi le sujet plus général
à juste titre par le chancelier Scholtz
de la défense aérienne du continent et
je pense que c'est un bon débat qui a
été posé par le chancelier c'est
pourquoi je souhaite qu'avec nos
partenaires allemands italiens
britanniques et tous ceux qui
souhaiteront s'y joindre en Europe nous
puissions lancer à Paris une conférence
sur la défense aérienne de l'Europe qui
permettra d'aborder ce sujet sous
l'angle industriel avec la participation
de tous les industriels européens qui
ont des solutions à offrir
mais aussi sous l'angle stratégique et
je dirais peut-être d'abord sous l'angle
stratégique en incluant la question de
la dissuasion et celle de la frappe dans
la profondeur
c'est à la condition de se réarmement
mental et matériels que nous permettrons
je le crois à l'Europe de tenir toute sa
place dans les futurs arrangements de
sécurité
mon quatrième appel est un appel à
imaginer quel genre de mécanisme
permettront durablement d'éviter le
cycle d'agression qu'a connu notre
continent ces dernières décennies
nous aurons besoin pour l'avenir d'un
cadre qui redonne de la transparence de
la prévisibilité sur le continent qui
doit respecter des principes simples
l'inviolabilité des frontières et la
souveraineté des États réaffirmait le
rôle stabilisateur de la dissuasion en
Europe rétablir un équilibre des forces
sur le continent rétablir une
architecture crédible de maîtrise des
armements permettant de ramener
progressivement l'équilibre des forces
au niveau le plus bas possible et enfin
mettre en place un cadre de règlement
des crises et des conflits prolongés sur
le continent en s'inspirant peut-être
des structures existantes comme le SCE
évidemment l'Europe doit être au coeur
de tout cela et comme vous le savez je
n'ai pas l'Europe dogmatique il y a bien
sûr l'Union européenne mais nous devons
penser une Europe plus large celle que
nous avons commencé de d'élaborer à
travers la communauté politique
européenne qui aura un rôle spécial à
jouer à cet égard incluant des
puissances qui ont parfois choisi de
quitter l'Union européenne mais reste
ancré dans les intérêts géopolitiques de
l'Europe
des puissances qui n'ont jamais rejoint
l'Union européenne mais sont nos
partenaires de sécurité d'énergie et de
temps de sujets
et des puissances qui aspirent à
rejoindre l'Union européenne peut-être
et je l'espère la rejoindront mais qui
aujourd'hui sont assez confins et donc
de la Norvège à nos amis britanniques en
passant par les balkansoccidentaux
jusqu'à la Moldavie et l'Ukraine cette
communauté politique européenne est un
cadre géopolitique pour permettre de
prévenir ces crises et d'en penser le
cadre et l'architecture et je veux à cet
égard redire notre soutien à la
présidente moldave Maya Sandu qui aura
organisé la prochaine réunion de la
communauté politique européenne et qui a
à vivre tant étant de défis
nous avons besoin de bâtir un nouvel
espace de coopération sur notre
continent et à cet égard l'OTAN joue un
rôle clé et je crois que ces derniers
mois ont permis de montrer que tous ceux
qui croyaient qu'une Europe de la
défense plus forte car renforcement du
pilier de défense européen était une
menace à l'OTAN ont bien compris qu'il
ne faisait que renforcer notre alliance
transatlantique
parce que tout ça s'est fait en parfaite
intelligence avec nos partenaires
américains canadiens et au-delà et que
nous avons montré notre volonté de
partager des objectifs stratégiques
communs
enfin je voudrais lancer deux derniers
appels très rapides un ensemble des
partenaires européens le cinquième appel
c'est qu'au-delà de ce conflit
aujourd'hui nous devons continuer
d'agir ensemble sur d'autres formes de
conflictualité qui sont déjà en train de
nous toucher peuvent nous menacer le
risque que nous avons tous à vivre c'est
d'aider comme nous devons le faire
l'Ukraine d'intensifier d'être face à
des défis géopolitiques majeurs dans les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois mais d'avoir à faire face aussi
à de nouvelles formes de conflictualité
dans des espaces nouveaux n'oublions pas
le cyber le spatial les espaces
maritimes et les vulnérabilités de nos
démocraties en matière de désinformation
et de déstabilisation ces risques là
seront utilisés
et ces espaces-là seront utilisés
peut-être par la Russie ou par d'autres
puissances autoritaires qui dans ce
contexte chercheront à nous déstabiliser
et donc nous devons renforcer notre
coopération nos investissements nos
capacités à coopérer aussi dans ces
champs dans la période actuelle et puis
ma dernière remarque mon dernier appel à
tous les Européens et au-delà je dirais
c'est un appel aux européens et aux
Américains
engageons-nous aussi dans la préparation
de la paix à court terme nous devons
être forts et montrer que nous sommes
forts et déterminés derrière l'Ukraine
est prêt à durer
mais nous devons dès maintenant préparer
les termes de la paix c'est notre
responsabilité
ça n'est pas un esprit de compromission
c'est un esprit de responsabilité cette
paix sera d'autant plus possible et
crédible si nous sommes forts
aujourd'hui si nous savons l'être dans
la durée mais nous devons en préparer
les termes et le faire c'est le faire en
réengageant celles et ceux qui
aujourd'hui
en Asie en le Pacifique au Proche et
Moyen-Orient en Afrique en Amérique
latine ne pense pas tout à fait dans les
termes que je viens d'expliquer et
malgré ce que je disais au début de mon
promo mon propos continue de dire il y a
des doubles standards vous dépensez
énormément pour l'Ukraine et vous
continuez de pas dépenser pour nous vous
battez avec beaucoup de force contre la
guerre là pas suffisamment contre la
pauvreté chez nous on a une guerre chez
nous depuis des décennies vous en avez
pas fait le centième sachons les
entendre
et donc il nous faut réengager
diplomatiquement avec toutes ces
géographies pour les convaincre de
rejoindre notre effort de pression sur
la Russie et de préparation de la paix
c'est notre responsabilité et il faut le
faire en conjurant en particulier
cette espèce de récit du double standard
qui s'installe c'est pourquoi au moment
même où nous faisons tous ces
investissements
j'appelle les Européens les Américains
tous les membres du G7 et au-delà du G20
à nous accompagner sur la reconstruction
d'un partenariat Sud Nord pour permettre
de repenser les termes de la solidarité
internationale et investir massivement
vers les pays qui en ont besoin pour
leur santé leur éducation la lutte
contre l'insécurité alimentaire et pour
permettre précisément de redonner de la
crédibilité à tous les pays riches
qui doivent réengager beaucoup
d'émergence de pays à revenus
intermédiaires de pays en voie de
développement dans cet effort en leur
montrant qu'au moment où nous défendons
nos principes où nous voulons une paix
juste et durable aux conditions des
Ukrainiens en Ukraine nous ne les
oublions pas et nous voulons un monde
plus juste capable de faire face aux
défis climatiques et à ses conséquences
chez eux comme ailleurs
cette responsabilité est indispensable
et ne l'oublions pas en quelque sorte la
réponse à ce nouveau contexte
géopolitique doit passer par un
investissement militaire doit passer par
une fermeté mais aussi une capacité à
nous engager sur une paix crédible et à
nous engager sur une politique de
solidarité redoublée j'ai déjà été trop
long je ne serais pas davantage merci en
tout cas de m'accueillir parmi vous et
de me permettre de partager avec vous
ces quelques convictions
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup merci en fait deux
questions OK
merci pour votre allocution il y a un
avantage et un inconvénient l'avantage
c'est un discours qui a couvert de
nombreux domaines mais malheureusement
l'inconvénient et que nous n'avons pas
le temps de prendre des questions donc
je ne vais pas vous poser moi-même mes
questions mais je vais me tourner vers
le public qui n'a pas pu poser des
questions aux chancelier allemand
donc nous avons le temps pour deux
questions
que nous allons prendre l'une après
l'autre immédiatement la première
le pour la première personne n'a pas le
besoin de
lever la main Françoise
très court
c'est le président est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il y a une chance quelconque
pour qu'il puisse y avoir une paix
durable avec la Russie puisque vous avez
dit qu'elle allait rester en Europe si
la Russie n'a pas fait son deuil
d'Empire comme l'avait fait le général
de Gaulle on s'entend s'agissant de la
fin de la guerre d'Algérie et est-ce que
vous voyez les traces la possibilité
qu'il puisse y avoir un tel empire
je vais poser ma question en anglais
monsieur le Président dans votre vision
d'un nouvel ordre mondial et d'une paix
durable est-ce que cela inclut le fait
que le Conseil de sécurité donne plus de
place et plus de pouvoir aux autres pays
si vous permettez je vais commencer avec
la question la deuxième question oui je
pense que nous devons
redéfinir notre Ordre Mondial
je pense que c'est une
urgence de premiers ordre pour rendre
notre infrastructure de sécurité plus
inclusive et je suis impressionné du
rythme auquel nous perdons la confiance
du Sud global
pourquoi
et bien je pense que pendant très
longtemps pour des bonnes raisons en
partie le monde était déséquilibré la
pandémie de covid-19
a montré notre double standard dans
notre approche que nous avons eu
je nous avons fait beaucoup un travail
incroyable la conférence de Munich à
c'est un travail majeur quand on est
plus de parole plus d'espace au pays de
Free de sud et nous avons fait
beaucoup mais ce n'est pas suffisant
évidemment il y a un critère majeur
c'est le critère financier et donc ce
que nous voyons aujourd'hui c'est n'est
pas seulement la conséquence de cette
guerre donc comme quand nous disons
c'est notre priorité principale cette
guerre nous avons besoin de de dépenser
de l'argent et ce qui est essentiel
c'est l'échelle et la rapidité mais
évidemment nous avons la démographie le
changement climatique ce sont des
priorités pour d'autres pays
donc c'est une question de solidarité
qui est essentielle mais qu'il faut
rétablir il faut rétablir la conscience
et pourquoi je crois dans cette nouveau
dans ce nouveau partenariat entre le Sud
et le nord nous organiserons une
conférence à Paris en juin avec le
représentant du pays du Sud afin de
soutenir et d'accélérer les réformes du
FMI de la Banque mondiale pour
redessiner c'est cette architecture
internationale et il se tord
international et offrir plus
d'inclusivité dans ces forums mondiaux
mais il faut le dire aussi un membre du
permanent du Conseil de sécurité a
décidé de jeter à terre de foulées au
pied tous les principes sur lesquels
sont basés cette ordre internationale
il faut essayer de comprendre
la pensée russe et la perspective russe
je n'essaye pas de junissent justifier
j'essaye de comprendre
c'est une guerre qui est une conséquence
d'un fait que probablement personne n'a
pris en compte en Europe c'est à dire la
fin de la guerre froide
ni les Européens ni les Russes n'ont
vraiment digéré cette période et cette
césure
côté ouais on faisait le mur tombe et
tout va bien c'est une période de l'une
de miel qui s'est ouvert on rejoint
l'Union européenne tout va bien
et
c'est à dire qu'on a abandonné l'essai
de côté tout ce qui avait été construit
pendant des décennies et donc forcément
on y a des conséquences nous avons
sous-estimé sans aucun doute
l'importance des cultures nationales
dans certains pays actuellement de
l'Union européenne nous avons
sous-estimé les crises
profondes
qui ont accompagné cette transition et
j'en ai déjà parlé il y a déjà quelques
années et peut-être que je m'en suis
saisi trop tard mais c'est vrai que je
n'ai été élu qu'en 2017 et c'est la
question de la relation à la Russie
et c'est vrai que la Russie non plus n'a
pas digéré cette transition je pense que
la Russie n'a pas digéré la fin de son
empire
et la raison profonde de l'agression de
l'Ukraine c'est la
rancoeur de
là aussi et l'obsession russe de
l'Empire russe le PIB moyen
démographique décline le plus grand pays
du monde avec de grands de très grandes
frontières avec la Chine qui est
beaucoup plus forte donc si vous voulez
survivre il vous faut avoir des rêves
fou donc là c'est le rêve de la
croissance de l'innovation que qui
pourrait avoir et puis vous avez
d'autres choix le rêve
d'un nouvel d'une nouvelle Europe basée
sur la paix et l'innovation et
l'éducation
où vous vous tournez vers l'ancien rêve
de l'Empire et vous le ressusciter
j'en suis je suis tout à fait sceptique
quant à la capacité
à suscité ce type d'Empire à terme mais
je n'en vois pas
les signes nous avons coureurs
je ne crois pas une seule seconde à la
théorie d'un changement de régime
j'entends beaucoup de personnes appelées
à un changement de régime et je leur
demande mais quel changement qui doit
prendre le relais qui est le leader
ce changement de régime et nous avons
déjà défendu des changements de régime
dans de nombreux pays et cela toujours
mené à des échecs
donc nous avons le régime russe ces
obsessions son peuple
nous voulons tout d'abord rétablir la
souveraineté et l'intégrité territoriale
de l'Ukraine
[Musique]
puisse pour que
nous voyons que les si un changement de
régime le nouveau régime aura les mêmes
rêves et donc les mêmes que nous
causerons les mêmes difficultés il faut
arriver à partager un rêve commun qui
soit durable et commun à tous ce sera
difficile je pense qu'il est trop tôt
pour formuler à ses rêves et ses
perspectives mais je pense qu'il est
important merci monsieur le Président
il y a des questions qui n'ont pas
auxquelles il n'a pas été répondu
j'espère que vous reviendrez pour
répondre à ces questions merci
merci Monsieur
pour votre invitation et bonne
continuation à nos amis ukrainiens